(urinates)
- Oh my god.
- Ella and Eugene are getting married!
- No...
- Effing...
- Way.
- So I guess you probably figured out
why I invited all of you here.
Will you be my groomsmen?
- Yes, yes!
- So obviously, Steve
is gonna be my best man.
- What?
- Oh my god, look at these,
they're one of a kind!
- I was best man at my
brother's wedding, so...
- Oh, that's really wonderful.
- [Male friend] Steve,
if you need any hot tips,
I got you covered bro!
- Oh, no man, don't worry
about it, I got this.
- Who the (bleep) does Max think he is?
- Um, who's this?
- Oh, this is my cousin, Justin.
- To best friends.
Yo, I don't know why I'm not the best man.
I'm Eugene's cousin, I don't know.
- Best friends.
- [Max] Steven is in way over his head.
He's gonna get overwhelmed
and drop the ball,
and when he does I'll
be there to scoop it up.
- We should probably see what the
bridesmaids look like, right?
- On it.
Look at those arms.
- Let's see, what's her
relationship status say?
Oh, she doesn't have it.
I really hope I find love
at this wedding, you know?
Maybe even get married myself, who knows?
- If you don't like this place
you don't have to go here.
- Come on, let's go.
- It's like a cool, Brazilian New Years.
- I think it's like a cool
Brazilian coke dealer.
- I mean, your butt looks great.
- [Eugene] Thanks.
- Nope, nope, no way, ew.
- [Steve] No!
- That looks good.
(all gasp)
- [Eugene] It's the one.
- [Max] Oh my god, it's so soft.
- [Eugene] Guys, don't mess up the suit.
I still have to buy it--
- Yeah, don't mess up the suit.
Steven, get off him.
- [Eugene] It's okay, but thank you.
- Are you ready to get
hot for this wedding?
- I'm ready to get hot for this wedding!
- Let's do it!
(fast workout music)
- I haven't eaten gluten in two months.
- Yeah, I'm on a strict liquid diet.
- I take three cold showers a day
because the shivering burns calories.
- Wait, our outfits are pink
oxfords and yellow bow ties?
- Are you kidding me, when am
I ever gonna wear that again?
- Just got a super
passive aggressive email
from Steve about the bachelor party.
It's probably gonna be really tacky.
(dance music)
- I can't believe you
guys got vagina straws.
- Surprise, surprise!
Vagina cake!
- Can we get five more
cosmos for us, thank you.
- Make that six!
Actually no, we're just gonna have five.
Justin, you're drunk.
- [Steve] That was a
70 dollar vagina cake.
The wedding is tomorrow and I can't wait
for it to be over because
I am losing my mind!
(alarm beeping)
It's here!
Wake up, ya sons of bitches!
We're already late!
- It's 4:30 in the morning.
- [Steve] Yes!
- Didn't wanna step on your toes,
but I was starting to wonder when you
were gonna wake up these sleepy heads.
- [All] You're getting married today!
- Alright, here ya go.
Get your coffee, we got
a big schedule ahead.
(glasses clink)
(knock on door)
Maid of honor's here!
- [Male friend] Oh god,
do not look at my hair.
- I have a card from Ella.
It's like a love note or something.
(gentle music)
- I can't find my suspenders.
- Somebody needs to go on
a run to the rental car.
- Everyone look for the keys first.
We can't find the keys.
- Got 'em.
- [Steve] Oh, thank you for
scaring the hell out of us.
- Why are you guys all dressed up?
- Are you kidding me right now?
- (mumbling) shirt!
- Everything okay out here?
- Everything's great.
- I need help with my suit.
- Did Steve tie this for you?
- That looks fantastic.
Yeah, I tied it.
- I'm sorry, I'm gonna retie it.
- No, it looks good.
- Because it looks like a blind person--
- Okay, you know what, can I
speak with you for a second?
Ever since he decided
that I was the best man,
you have been a negative
nancy and a pouty--
- I dunno what you're doing in his head.
You are singlehandedly trying to
take my best friend away from me!
- Someone hold my hair back.
- [Steve] Oh, god, oh god.
(girls cheering)
- [All] Ball and chain!
- You're never gonna
screw any guys ever again!
- Alright, three, two, one...
(violin music)
- Did the maid of honor, like, wake up
five minutes before this wedding started?
- Did she even care about this?
- God damn her arms in that dress.
- I mean, the one in the
middle is the lawyer, right?
(groomsmen gasp)
- [Officiant] Do you take Ella in sickness
and in health, as long
as you both shall live?
- [Eugene] I do.
- [Officiant] Ella, do you
take Eugene in sickness
and in health, as long
as you both shall live?
- [Ella] I do.
- [Officiant] You may kiss the groom.
(audience cheers)
(hip hop music)
(friends cheering)
- Okay, here's the deal, here's the deal.
I've known Ella for a really long time.
Eugene, you're a cool dude, you took my
best bitch from me, but
like, I think you guys
are gonna be really happy and
marriage is awesome, so...
Cheers to these two!
(friends cheer)
And any available groomsmen,
come see me later.
- Single over here, so...
- So I've known Eugene
for a long time now.
Probably longer than any
of his other friends.
When we took a trip to Big Sur last year,
he said, "Steve, I met this girl."
And I said, "What's her name?"
And he said, "Her name is Ella."
And I said, "Ella,
that's beautiful. I mean,
that's what the Greeks call
Greece, they call it Ellas."
And I was like, "Is she the one, Eugene?"
And he said, "Steve...
"I know."
And I just wanna say, may you love
each other more every single day.
I love you, Eugene.
(friends cheering)
- We love you, we love you, we love you!
- Hey, Steven.
- Max.
- That was a beautiful speech.
- You know, I couldn't have
done today without your help.
I'm not the best man, we're the best men.
- Get over here, hermano.
(friends cheer)
- I don't know if I can
do another wedding, man.
- No, no way.
- It was a really pretty ceremony.
- It was adorable.
- He looked amazing.
- He looked incredible.
(phones beep)
- [All] No effing way!
(all laugh)
- [Male friend] Literally all of our
friends are getting married.
- [Steve] Every one of 'em.
- Hey, wanna get out of here?
- Uh, it's happening.